welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and what was that backstabbing Elia Kane
up to in Mandalorian season three why
did she double cross that poor doctor
Pershing like that just for some cloning
supplies well if you look at all the
clues that lucasfilm seems to be
dropping in their Disney Plus shows and
Beyond I believe that you can quite
clearly see that they're trying to tell
us all the secret ingredients needed to
create one supreme leader snoke and
basically Palpatine's Grand secret plan
to terrorize the Galaxy so let's find
that all out together my nerd babies but
like always be sure to head on over to
nerdriot.shop where you can pick up one
of our new Mandalorian inspired shirts
or our other designs based on you know
Super Mario and the last of us
nerdrive.shop is the best way to support
the channel head on over to
nerdrive.shop today alright how does
this new season of the Mandalorian
specifically chapter 19 tie into Emperor
Palpatine's secret plans to secure power
in the Galaxy after his death and what
have lucasfilm heads Kathleen Kennedy
and Dave filoni been planning with their
secret narrative that spans across the
Star Wars Disney Plus shows like Obi-Wan
Kenobi and Andor well in a nutshell
Emperor Palpatine's main goal was to
secure himself the most powerful force
sensitive body to resurrect in should
his old frail body in the bathrobe be
tossed down a tube by an angry black
cyborg Samurai deadbeat dad one day who
knows maybe it'll happen
and one of the key instruments that
Palpatine was relying on to secure his
return to power with a little science
nerd by the name of pen Pershing the
Imperial cloning scientist that was
working with moff Gideon secure that old
green ass baby grogu and the scientists
who got his brain put in a futuristic
air fryer in Mando chapter 19 and Dr
Pershing even hints at Palpatine's
immense interest in cloning research at
the top of his speech to the new
Republic sadly my research was twisted
into something cruel and inhumane at the
behest of a desperate individual intent
on using cloning technology to secure
more power for himself but what did the
emperor and his loyal subject is in
Kane emphasis on the what did the
emperor and his loyal subject Elia Kane
want to do with pershing's cloning
related experiments on a tiny green baby
anyway well remember when Mando and the
Gang ran into that weird tube in season
2 episode 4 with what appeared to be a
prototype supreme leader snow clone
inside well I believe that's because
that's exactly what that Abomination was
an early fail snow cloning experiment of
a type of Clone that Persian refers to
as a strand cast in chapter 19 and
according to pershing's grandcast are a
type of Clone that he and his Science
Buddies were working on that essentially
involves taking the DNA of multiple
people and creating a new being from
that DNA thanks to the groundbreaking
work of the Cameron Owens we know that
cloning can duplicate an individual from
a single genetic strand what my work
explored was the hopes of combining
multiple strands to create replicas that
incorporated the best genetic attributes
of both donors and a strand cast clone
is exactly what it was revealed that
Supreme Leader's note was all along when
kylo Ren arrives at Palpatine's secret
Sith cloning facilities on the planet
exego as a bunch of snoke strandcast
clones can be seen in a tube but this
raises two important questions one if
snoke is a strand cast clone then whose
DNA is snow even made out of because the
last time I checked snoke didn't look
anything like a tiny green baby unless I
wasn't wearing my glasses and two if
snoke isn't part wrong you then why the
hell did the emperor need Roku in the
first place well the answer to that
second question comes in Mando season 2
after team Mando discover a recording of
Dr perching in the laboratory of that
failed snoke strank ass clone in that
recording we learned the exact reason
why Pershing and the emperor were
interested in Roku and it was not for
the purposes of cloning rogu but instead
to capitalize on the potential of
grobu's blood in particular rogu's M
count replicated the results of the
subsequent trials which also resulted in
catastrophic failure there were
promising effects for an entire
Fortnight but then sadly the body
rejected the blood I highly doubt we'll
find a donor with a higher end count
though with M count referring of course
to midichlorians the tiny microscopic
creatures that live in perfect symbiotic
harmony with every living being in the
galaxy and connect them with the force
basically the more of these little
midichlorian guys that you have living
inside of your blood cells the stronger
your connection to the force will be
when Qui-Gon Jinn found Anakin Skywalker
in Star Wars Episode 1 he took a blood
sample and discovered that Anakin's
blood contained a crazy high amount of
midichlorians that greatly surpassed the
quantity found in any known Jedi even
those found within the blood of Master
Yoda whose mysterious green species that
grogu and yado belong to seems to
naturally produce a lot of midichlorians
in the blood at Birth thus making the
force extremely easy to connect to for
roku's race and look guys I like to live
in the now as in I need energy right now
I don't have time to run to the store to
grab coffee or something so I just pop
one of these a One-Shot energy
um well I feel the energy coming to my
body already Jesus Christ
once your Energy Chews are a healthy and
convenient energy boosting supplement
candy for gamers athletes YouTube hosts
and everyone really each energy shoe has
75 milligrams of pure caffeine plus 600
milligrams of additional new cropics to
give you a serious energy boost that
works immediately as you chew and man
does it work like as I was chewing that
I felt the alertness and power coursing
through my veins like put it directly
into my veins I say the focus shoes are
great when you need to concentrate and
they give you a natural boost of energy
with BCD and E vitamins plus zinc to
help with immune system supports and the
amino acid tyrosine but my favorite
ingredient is the blue raspberry flavor
rasposine both Energy Chews and focus
shoes are plant-based naturally
sweetened and designed to give you the
energy and focus that you need without a
bunch of fillers and chemicals and
so get started with one shot energy
today by going to one shotenergy.com new
rockstars for 10 off of your order that
is oneshotenergy.com new rockstars for
10 off your order and think one shot
energy for sponsoring this video and
giving all the viewers the extra shot of
energy that they need to survive and
thrive and be nerdy all the time the
reason why I believe supreme leader
snoke was so freaking powerful in the
force and the sequels was because
Palpatine injected a crazy amount of
midichlorians within a strand cast clone
puppet midichlorians that Palpatine
stole from hundreds of the strongest
horse-sensitive people in the galaxy and
if the emperor is going to experiment
with the midichlorians of force
sensitive people he's going to need a
place to store all those people that
he's kidnapping right and this is where
the Obi-Wan Kenobi show comes in in
particular that moment when Obi-Wan
sneaks into Palpatine's Fortress
inquisitorious and discovers a bunch of
Jedi being preserved in Amber is it a
funny how lucasfilm brought that up and
then never mentioned it again
isn't that weird I believe that this
moment was included in the Obi-Wan show
because it is a moment that is supposed
to be one that moves lucasfilm's
Narrative of Palpatine's resurrection
and revenge plans or where every new
piece of Star Wars media seems to be
working together to leave hints towards
how Palpatine did this even the freaking
video games like I don't know if you
guys remember the Star Wars Battlefront
2 campaign but soon after the battle of
Endor Luke Skywalker ends up visiting a
planet called paleo that Palpatine
actually had a secret base on and pillio
was special because paleo was a planet
hovered in Amber Amber that I believe
that the emperor would end up mining
from paleo and bringing to the Fortress
inquisitorious why to preserve the
midichlorians of the Jedi that he
kidnapped for experimentation because
midichlorians only exist in living
beings so he had to preserve them that
tomb in the Fortress inquisitorius is
actually the emperor's midichlorian
stats where he farmed Jedi blood like
those scientists in Jurassic Park took
dinosaur blood from that mosquito stuck
in Amber but let's get back to that
first question from before if snoke is
indeed a strand cast clone with multiple
DNA samples inside of him whose DNA was
combined to make Stoke this is where the
Andor show comes in because remember
Andy's circus's Kino Loy character who
is a supremely good leader who kept all
those prisoners in line with nothing but
fear and the power of His super strong
voice until he was inspired by Andor to
lead a prison break yeah I don't think
things ended too well for our friend
Kino Emperor Palpatine is a petty man
who always liked to capitalize on his
failing although Palpatine did lose some
of his death star Workforce in that
Prison Break Palpatine gained the
knowledge of the power of Kino Lloyd's
commanding voice and leadership ability
we will never have a better chance than
this
and I would rather die trying to take
them down than giving them what they
want that
ends today
there is one way out right now
building is us so what do I think the
emperor did he killed Kino Loya of
course for starting a rebellion because
rebellions would not be tolerated in the
Empire but not without securing Kino's
DNA and mixing it with his own to strand
cast clone a new kind of leader a
supreme leader for his new first order
with a crazy high end count from all the
midichlorians Palpatine shoved inside of
this new clone but yes this is the
secret narrative that I believe that
lucasfilm is teasing with all of their
Star Wars shows to try to explain how
Palpatine returns and supreme leader
snoke's Origins but anyways thank you
guys so much for watching this video you
can follow me at mrtainment on Twitter
if you guys want to see me tweet some
weird and some really fun theories
but more importantly you can fall into
rockstars wherever we are on the social
media but yes thank you guys again for
watching and I'll see you guys next time
goodbye
[Music]
thank you